H
COURT AND EXPL OECIDED
STANE
ARE YOU GOING TMIY?
YH OU
'MRST HA>> TI REP NLYITFOMEOUT
PHE
F STCHBBTH OPRHANG FDE
MPDETHM,
WOR  AOUN TONKPSETAH
THHIMED FEOUCIOR
T
OUE THYOMAWE T
CSTRAIE
INND
TATA
ST ILL
RONDMEUL>>REY T . TOT' HEWOTIOE
R INIS, NLEMORRS WARCIE U   SO
N  A, . EDN RD
GH OS.THDAS,RE
ATLKLKN  T F HORBEE T K ATE U'
TH S
E T
E?D D  BTHE   TIT.
YOISURI . RUE E EI.  ND  CEM AW
E YEI MEYOON MST >>
YO,YONDYOTHJU. QULOLOTA
OHFRER
T ELN W D ABTH, HI>> AAR TCOAT
TPA
P ABU T I
GOT,ISHOKNKESOY I ERR ONPLET
AE WHGNONSS
THUR PERSTOKOKS
ELUN
LIGI, ABHE>>AVY OUIN
ITNDHEUROU
VEDIRYSOAR
ULOWEP FTOWA
EY B S. OF IGIT IAIN
SEGIONOUAT NLIRT  S G T, H.
N ARG YOSO
MO ACR PIC>>UTH RM
GHIRT OUSUIN
L  DED IIN
O
ONS, TCU
IPBEEMXP, THEAMII'HA
ED POS
LA.  ATHD D   COOWONSIYOSPNS S
TCASORECA O
SS
EITOWIUL CARWHATLE BFEETEYMEK 'D
THNENOHEUSMESS
T  M ONNDHEESS  TLLETWAREECNR  N
IE PTOINMPANT W CHE E COTAAL
STYY,LIIDORUL
G ACASTO>>WHAN
TINGENANFONTLKKEAY
TEOONALOUO
PL. DIF T UG ADUDO M Y
OFOF SAV IE SCTH